[Music]
alright ladies and gentlemen welcome to
another episode of gonna do that no you
didn't click on the wrong they were so
joking
people missed at the fields ok true yeah
I miss asked it feels even as editing it
I was like man yeah yeah out of all the
things that we were doing at the time
that was my favorite thing to work on
most of the videos were about dick sizes
oh my god I had a hard time I had a hard
time picking out messages cuz like 99%
of it was like is my dick good enough
time guys yes your dick is perfect your
dick is really good but I'm not gonna
talk about your dick today because today
I just want to talk about something a
little bit deeper than dicks all right
no how do you know when someone is the
one when they have the right dick size
wait how many of you found the one
because we're not married
how did you guys know you guys found the
one I don't know I Cecilia it's one of
those it's a feeling that you've never
felt before with someone else I think
that what if you feel a lot of feelings
with people that you'd never felt before
what negative feeling like I mean it has
to be good feelings but I mean like this
negative feelings that obviously I don't
think they're the one for me but I don't
know it's just you you feel at home oh
that's so sentimental I feel like that's
the best way I can describe it like when
I feel like I found that one is like oh
I feel like I'm at home what does home
feel like to you mmm
I could be like anywhere and you
actually like what does that feel like
like it warm is it like it's warm it's
reassuring and then it's like it's like
very fuzzy because I could fart in front
of a hookup well yeah I mean that's
what I mean that is the one right like
because you feel relaxing at home I feel
at home
but you feel happy all the time like you
feel good I feel wait a minute I found
the one and I don't feel happy it's
different for every person I feel like
my my answer is is so like so
metaphysical kind of like you know that
kind of thing I feel like it's much more
like how we can tackle the same problems
together and I was like a unit rather
than feeling oh I'm doing this thing I'm
doing this thing you know I feel like
it's how well we can communicate and
work at things together good being
together isn't about like the fact that
all two people just match it's like how
do you both learn to understand it
because learning to understand each
other throughout the years is part of
the whole thing that's the whole
challenge
you're not just do positive pieces that
fit automatically I mean for some people
do they do but a lot of times is like
how do you learn to be with this other
person you know and how do how do you
solve problems together yeah I mean even
the most loving couples that I feel like
are perfect for each other I still see
them fight yeah like it's there's no way
you could get away from this without
friction sure I mean that's relationship
relationship is two different people who
think they are a match who find out
there they're not really a hundred
percent match and they need to figure
out those differences and kind of living
with those differences and but that's
the challenge is the way do you think
and how do we use the way I think to
both come to the same conclusion yeah I
think hard yeah I think for me and TIFF
it's like I actually kind of had this
like revelation just the other night
where I was like oh we're so different
that we're like opposites are the phrase
opposites attract
oh you're going up every time you were
like coming up with that
like way over my offend my head yeah
yeah I think opposites really help
balance yeah it is hard it's frustrating
you get some arguments you're gonna like
like my ways better than your way kind
of conversation was it at right
everything yeah but but that that's the
best part is in like I know I'm like
really introverted and I know Tiff's
very extroverted and because of that we
kind of like she pushes me to be like
hey why not try this try to go out and
do this and I feel that I'll be cool and
then for me it's like you know what
there's some fun stuff we could do at
home I want to do this and we might stay
a homebody stay you know and we kind of
push each other into the areas that we
wouldn't normally want to do so I think
that's great like like I need to find
someone that likes my passion and stuff
like that and then whenever I did have
that person I was like this is why I
literally like we're just learning
nothing new you came yourself yeah how
do people they're very good-looking when
they look people know other people Ratna
demos like I just jacked off today but
then if it's someone that's like
opposite and they're like super loud
because I'm not and then they do the
stuff that I don't it's kind of fun
because it pushes you and you feel safe
with them right they don't judge you
when you're doing that and then they
could be loud and crazy and even though
you're calm they feel comfortable to do
that around you and you're not judging
you're just quiet you're just being you
so I like when people would do stuff
like that I just can't like I think in
terms of that it's like you're never
gonna find that person that's perfect
yeah you're not gonna fight and you
can't just look at people online and be
like I need that unless you and if you
don't find that that's not the right
person yeah the unicorn concept and they
all found a unicorn doesn't be perfect
we'll never fight yeah I mean like a
nobody grows up the same way right so
everybody learns their expectations in
different ways we heard Jo stories it
doesn't match any of ours
I gotta find my childhood friends no
with me and Bart um I actually felt like
so before Bart I didn't really believe
in marriage I didn't believe in love not
that I was jaded in any sort of way but
it love are like falling in love or
being in love to me sounded like a like
a movie concept it sounded like
something that was like may believe and
like where people were kind of
brainwashed to buy into that and for me
I always felt like you find the person
that you're compatible with and somehow
that turns into falling in love and then
so I always felt like I would have to
like meet in the middle or compromise in
some sort of way to like make a
relationship work
yeah but until I met Bart like when I
first met him it felt like I had met him
already like it was a [ __ ] weirdest
[ __ ] like it felt like I had not even
that type of person like I don't I can't
say I really buy it to [ __ ] like that or
I look look that [ __ ] up but he really
did feel like I like our souls had met
at some other point and I just I just
couldn't get the concept of like not
having this person in my life not in my
head so for me it was just this gut
feeling of like this is the one although
I do feel like he is my soul mate and
everything but we've had the [ __ ]
roughest [ __ ] relationship anyone
could everything because we're so
opposite and we raised so different and
loved our own trauma is that like you
know that I mean we all have traumas
right and like you try to work it out so
it doesn't matter if you find this soul
mate like that you got to work for it
like and and we've been together almost
13 years now and like we're spit like
every day or thank you like every day
we're still working at it like you've
been as - JK
yeah yeah maybe like - you guys started
like maybe two years damn I was 11 oh no
[ __ ] child
yes what is what is what people say the
one bill right I feel like it's so up to
interpretation yeah I think that's also
why my hand kind of went slow too
because both of my girlfriend are we've
talked about how like the one it's not
so much as like oh there's only one
person on the entire rate exactly I feel
like there's the ones there is there's
the ones you're like been in and in each
interaction is an opportunity for you
both to create an awesome space to help
each other develop yeah cuz even though
things didn't work out between me and
Jess I felt like it was a great
opportunity cuz I learned so [ __ ]
much and that I don't know if there's
really the one I think there's the
moment yeah and some people's moments
are much longer than others yeah yeah I
think people don't understand that
because they they're so scared of like
missing out on the one or yeah I lost
the what and they're never gonna find
love again that they don't realize that
there's more people with better people
out there and you're gonna constantly
grow and like when you look back at it
they actually weren't yeah but you just
get so lost in the moment and you do
dumb stuff because your brain tricks you
every [ __ ] time you know your brain
will play a trick in any time you talk
to anyone if it's like they're just
giving you attention when someone else
wasn't even at all this is the one and
it's it's infatuation mixed with it too
like in the early stages you're so
excited because you know like they say
you don't know their flaws they seem so
perfect yeah
and that becomes all convoluted and you
know people get married really [ __ ]
fast too like it's fair I haven't seen
situations where people are in a
relationship for six seven plus years
you know usually it's like a couple
years on the average and then they get
married I want to live with my partner
like yes with Valley City or to book the
ultimate test it is a test so much
changes from that but I think it helps
when cuz you might meet the one but it
might not be the one that's ready for
you right now
because um I think the perfect person is
when you both love yourself and you both
are self-aware that's when you can have
some connections yeah but if you don't
have that I don't think you'll ever find
the one because it looks like a clown
all the time you know it's just just
because like knowing Joe like when I
first started and then knowing him now
he's oh you haven't been around that
much that's why it's just a different
joke months ago look who the [ __ ] are
you Joe what's going on it's just like
him having like a heart to heart like
kind of piece of advice is like you got
to love yourself before you can love
someone else I like Joe yeah that's a
good thing man Thank You mr. Kinney Joe
people always take that in the wrong way
when you say like you I learned to love
yourself and that doesn't mean like you
become completely understanding but like
so you have past drama that you're
bringing it to your new relationship
that's love yourself if you spill your
insecurities all over the people around
ya and then it's not you act like
they're the ones doing something wrong
are you putting that on them but until
you learn to not get over that you won't
ever find happiness true love for
yourself is when you go out and buy a
Lamborghini and a Rolex
yeah Rolex and you say me first yeah I
think it's just more of like having
confidence in yourself and that you
shouldn't really doubt yourself no Joe's
right your is when you put yourself
first and stop putting others first and
what you should go first and foremost is
go out there and grab your lovers money
and go ahead and spend it on who you
love the most which is yourself amen all
right
[Applause]
[Music]